there are some republicans already
endorsing donald trump for 2024. donald
trump hasn't even announced he's running
in 2024 and one of the things pat and i
spoke about yesterday on the
award-winning bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad is that this 2024
presidential election may be the most
interesting and unique presidential
election i will have ever covered and
probably that i'll ever have been alive
for think about what we could be heading
towards uh that i have been alive for so
far i don't wanna you know in the future
anything could happen
we could have
the incumbent president joe biden
not run for reelection
the sitting vice president kamala harris
trying for the nomination and losing it
potentially she's very unpopular right
now that's just a fact that's not my
opinion kamal harris is perfectly fine
person she's just not very popular right
now so you could have biden say i'm not
running for reelection harris saying i
am running and democratic voters might
choose someone else so the sitting vp
might lose
the democratic nomination
on the republican side you could have a
former president one-term president
donald trump who lost was removed from
office
trying to become the nominee
that alone would be unique and he may
also lose it's not obvious that donald
trump would win he probably would win
based on current polling but ron
desantis is surging every two weeks
every week or two ron desantis is doing
better and better in 2024 betting
markets that i can't think of another
time when that's happened
sitting president doesn't run vp tries
for the nomination up against a one-term
president also trying for the nomination
so trump not even running some
republicans already endorsing him here's
jim jordan a horrible person by any
stretch of the imagination
saying what we need is trump back in the
white house simple video so uh yeah but
this will not change until donald
trump's back in the white house and we
get a commander-in-chief who knows how
to lead but you're absolutely right
hundreds of pilots okay so jim jordan
says we need trump back in the white
house congresswoman lauren bobert or bo
bear
she has put up a trump 2024
flag
at shooter's grill which i guess is her
restaurant in colorado or something so
she's already on trump 2024.
marco rubio has said if trump runs
then yeah i would support him here's an
interview
from a few months ago for marco rubio a
florida republican senator the senator
added that he's confident the state's
2022 election cycle is secure looking
ahead to 2024 i asked senator rubio if
he would support donald trump for
another term as president
yeah look if donald trump is going to
run for president in 2024 he'll be the
republican nominee and and of course i
would support him on that i mean we're
far long ways off from that a lot's
going to happen between now and then
true
so there's marco rubio who says he would
support trump if trump were the nominee
and then i mean this is just it's almost
a little weird even mitch mcconnell
the senate now minority leader former
majority leader republican who has said
so many negative things about trump uh
has clashed with trump when it comes to
um the january six riots trump has been
attacking mcconnell for so long
even mitch mcconnell says yeah i mean if
he's the nominee i would support him
well there's a lot to happen between now
and 24 i've got at least four members
that i think are planning on running for
president plus some for some governors
and others there's no incumbent should
be a wide open race and fun for you all
to cover
if the president was the party's nominee
would you support him
the nominee of the party absolutely
yeah
so
for all the the negative things that
mitch mcconnell has said about trump and
how horrifying trump's actions were
around january 6 all of it
um oh yeah if he's the nominee of course
i'll support him i guess it sounds like
there's really no one that mitch
mcconnell wouldn't support over a
democrat if they were the party's
nominee and then republican senator from
south carolina tim scott says of course
this is from a few months ago of course
he would support donald trump if donald
trump runs again in 2024. now on the
other side of this the the other
interesting component to this
is that there's a growing list of
republicans
who are not going to be supporting
donald trump in 2024 and there's kind of
three buckets of republicans and this
may change as things go forward there's
the people already supporting trump 2024
even though he's not a candidate there's
those who are just waiting probably to
kind of put their finger to the wind and
see does it look like the party wants
trump again or is it looking like it's
going to be desantis or what what you
know they're kind of fair-weather trump
supporters and then you've got the
people who have said i am not supporting
donald trump ever again of course this
includes
liz cheney and adam kinzinger the two
republicans who are on the january 6th
committee but a former trump ally
arkansas governor asa hutchinson has
said he's not going to be supporting
trump or at least he may run against
trump he may run for the 2024 republican
nomination mitt romney who has said i
believe if trump runs he will win the
nomination
but he would have to do it without mitt
romney's support and there are others as
well so shaping up and i know that this
is very unlike me you know in 2012
um
when people were saying well no in 2013
when people were asking me questions
about the 2016 presidential i said we've
got to get past the 2014 midterm first
in 2017 when there was so much
discussion about 2020 i said we've got
to deal with the 2018 midterm first
this is an unusual situation so much of
the midterms relates directly to 2024
particularly when republicans are trying
to use the 2022 midterms to take control
of more state election systems so that
then they can give 24
to their nominee no matter who wins in
the actual voting and on and on and on
so this is a unique situation
in that the 22 and 24 elections are
inextricably linked
and as i mentioned at the top of the
segment 24 is looking like it could be
one of the wildest and most unusual
situations i've ever covered or even
lived through i mean you think about
1992 okay yeah bill clinton defeated one
term george h.w bush not the most common
scenario but nothing compared to sitting
president doesn't run vp tries maybe
loses former one-term president tries to
run maybe wins maybe loses that's wild
and i expect it to be absolutely insane
we're going to take a quick quick break
we're going to come back we're going to
examine
a radical republicans track record of
gaffes and try to ascertain
is she really
this dumb i mean i don't know any other
way to say it is she really this dumb
remember that saturday night donald
trump will be in alaska
trying to damage
lisa murkowski
republican senator lisa murkowski's
re-election campaign he doesn't like her
he calls her a rhino
um we will be live with that on youtube
twitch and facebook i hope you'll join
me but let's take a quick break plenty
more still to come today